e la tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
nuovo video sono fa vj oggi stiamo il
nuovo blog come ogni sabato
tanto per cambiare seguito di cominciare
consente di ripartire la fantasia ma che
questa settimana è stata vinta da
gabriele che ha fatto sto allora i
disegni e figo non mi sembra che tipo
più lo guardate e più diventa
inquietante
[Musica]
ok fatto che fa un freddo cane perché in
questi sta facendo un freddo cane io
sono costantemente in maniche corte con
il cappello di là a parte questo
passando le news allora c'è una roba
strana ma veramente strano ricordate
quando avevo detto che stavano facendo
album delle figurine la panini con le
figurine dei calciatori ste robe qui
diciamo che ultimamente negli ultimi
nell'ultimo periodo
negli ultimi due giorni incazzo periodo
mi sono arrivati un casino di messaggio
in a casa li possa di tipo fabio trovate
il tuo album in edicola e l'ho preso io
allora io mi avevano detto che sarebbe
uscito a fine marzo più o meno non mi
hanno detto la data precisa ma limite
quando mi avete scritto mi è arrivato un
miliardo di messaggi così c'è sono
andato a prenderlo di persone è stato
veramente e questo è ciechi che che
faccia sexy shop
la cosa strana ma mai stampare queste
cose è stato bellissimo perché sono
andato in edicola oggi ho chiesto al
tizio minimi dall album di famiglia tipo
di farfa vi fa il dj mi ha detto una
roba del genere vedete non fa tra vj
favilla album della panini nuovo ha
preso l'album è la data è affatto così
proprio così e stata una roba
imbarazzante imbarazzante giuro i
ragazzi si come me lo aveva chiesto
mezzo mondo da quando avevo parlato
tempo tipo mesi fa l'avevo detto che
sarebbe uscito prima o poi adesso è
uscito così perché veramente tanto
ragazzi al tempo avevo chiesto alla
panini proprio quando mi avevano fatto
l'album sarà una roba tipo willy wonka
dove si mettono delle golden card
all'interno di alcuni pacchetti proprio
rare che sono popolare e chi le trova
può passare una giornata con me come chi
come willy wonka proprio e loro l'hanno
veramente fatto ragazzi ci sono
veramente delle card al non so quante
sono ma ce ne sono veramente poche però
ci sono rapace che la trovo io sarebbe
tragico si possa passare una giornata
come stesso non vedo l'ora
la golden card a è fatta così può essere
possa fare le figurine con questa faccia
e non è così non so veramente no no no
non è possibile credo che comunque sarà
il secondo album che finirò in tutta la
mia vita dopo quello di dragon ball camo
finita dieci anni comunque passando ad
altri anche questo accendo oggi come
mancano siccome non c'è più lo scat
aggio dei pacchi da un casino di tempo
forse pensavo di fare anche lo scarto
delle figurine per vedere che cazzo
trovo solo per curiosi giu solo la
curiosità proprio no
6 se siete veramente veramente ho
trovato questa cosa questa verrà scambio
perché cazzo no ma no oggi no mi rifiuto
sacrifico poi dalla prossima si lamenti
poi non ce l'ho scartato di pacchi e
come al solito faccio vedere un qualcosa
che mi è successa durante la settimana
in qualcosa di strano ma strano proprio
sì come vi ho detto che non so non so
per niente guida io che la guida siamo
come trevor e la guida qualche giorno fa
ho guidato seriamente cioè seriamente si
fa per dire mi sono fatto riprendere
perché potevo morire quindi ho dovuto
immortalare
niente ragazzi siccome ripetendo il
video mi sono messo a ridere come un
[ __ ] da solo vi lascio a questa
incredibile esperienza di farisei che
guida non fatelo no c'è proprio non
fatevi guidare un fa vj nella vostra
vita ma le vite non ha reagito ma se
devo stare ferma qui ma che arriva
qualcuno allora stessi e in folle questa
merda sì se nostra già spenta prima
ok aspetta che non si matura madonna
bene beta 6 in prima rifaremo tirare giù
le freak la frizione la frizione è
spenta ma aspettano che tutelari accendi
si spegne di fare una sezione perfezione
non il cavo giu ok tu sei in folle altri
ex alla togli affezione intanto accelera
ragazzi piano piano sto andando
c'è la curva davanti ragazzi si sono
occhi che c'è il marciapiede avanti a te
fermi farmi farmi affidata ragazzi
trevor in confronto è un guidatore
perfetto ma era anche giro madonna
sembra mia nonna o cazzo terminati o due
stelle già lo faccio li suono no io sono
nato lì sì sì adesso sappiamo la padania
via via via via via che ci si gira tutto
il volante di qua un cazzo non vedere
adesso tira giù come si fa devi tirare
giù la frizione intanto frenare due
piedi 18 tiri giù una fazione intanto
freni
ok così bravo e mette in folle sono 52
ho rischiato seriamente timori di nuove
avere un parcheggio però non lo farò mai
più nella mia vita non prenderò mai più
un mezzo di trasporto in tutta anche un
aereo c'è piuttosto se le mandano in
america vado a nuoto e detto queste
ragazzine che possiamo passare allo
studio
scatta gb a chi non c'ero quando gioco
io possiamo versare al fa vi risponde
avevo più cervelli in questa foto chiara
ricciardi chi poi permesso di tagliarti
i capelli c'è scusa zia non lo faccio
più giovani ma il jolly mars e se mangio
un limone ride pugni prendete per il
culo
beh il bello è che mi prende madonna
mangion limone e nel mentre canta blanks
per canta blank space di taylor ma che
problemi hai al cervelli come fa black
space fermina karaoke mio pezzo è mai
[Musica]
e stata la cosa più trash che io abbia
mai fatto in tutta la mia vita lemon dei
vip se non mangia fa vj tu gli hai anni
fa vi risponde favi sei vergine
io sono ma che belle ariete sono ariete
apri l'ariete che figo effetti speciali
in live proprio dai ragazzi prima di
concludere sono sexy con questa fortuna
veramente mi prude che la metà basta ai
pidocchi incorporati praticamente prima
di conclude ragazzi passano affari
domanda ed affari domanda di oggi e ci
sono due video speciali mettiamo gli
speciali tra virgolette che volevo fare
che sono un po diversi dei video
insoliti volevo fare google myself è una
cosa dovrei cercare il mio nickname su
internet commentare cose che escono
oppure a kinect ora ghazi quello fare
uno di questi due non lo so di temi il
vostro preferito così faccio quello per
prima e poi l'altro fatemi sembra
ragazzi ha concluso qui il video
sei tra gazzi 6 video è piaciuto come mi
piace anche a pagina di facebook e come
invitato atene sezione solisti discreti
lascivi dai ragazzi